thanks to Squarespace for sponsoring
this video where you can create your own
website in minutes for many people Apple
is a confusing company on one hand it's
an unquestionable success creating and
then dominating entire categories of
products and making more money than any
other business in the world by far but
somehow it also seems unable to
understand its customers removing
features we love neglecting its own
products and making bizarre trade-offs
we never asked for so how can the
world's most profitable company also be
so foolish many would say they can
afford these mistakes because of their
exceptional marketing others see them as
disorganized and distracted really only
coasting on earlyer success these
feelings are everywhere on the internet
and frankly they're understandable by
being such a secretive company they
sacrifice the chance to explain
themselves leaving us to speculate from
the outside but theories like these only
raise more questions if the goal is
simply marketing to maximize profit why
focus on so few products they should be
using their brand to sell anything and
everything like Samsung and why remove
things like the headphone jack these are
very deliberate decisions yet they
guarantee far more negative press than
they make in sales of adapters foolish
as they sound there must be some kind of
strategy here it would take a miracle
for a truly dysfunctional company to be
this successful for this long which
makes sense companies this big aren't
driven so much by individual employees
as institutional principles so you may
hate their strategy think they're
overpriced and disagree with every
decision they make but by no means are
they careless or arbitrary the only way
to make sense of all this to understand
their success predict their future and
even explain their mistakes is to figure
out how they think and just three
principles are enough to explain almost
everything this is the grand theory of
Apple
apple is treated as a technology company
and anything else would seem ridiculous
but it would also be ridiculous to say
its goals or anything like other
technology companies their business may
involve transistors and resistors but
from their perspective this is only
incidental technology is actually the
enemy a distraction a source of
confusion in the ideal world no one
cares about RAM or even knows they're
using a computer they're just drawing or
reading or talking
this may sound idealistic but consider
how much it explains it's why they're
obsessed with making devices thin light
and minimalistic removing ports bezels
and even buttons it also favors some
devices over others because from their
perspective each device is fundamentally
competing in the same category which
their executive Phil Schiller said quite
openly quote the job of the watch is so
you don't need to pick up your phone is
often the job of the phone is to do more
and more things such that maybe you
don't need your iPad the job of the iPad
is to be so powerful and capable that
you never need a notebook the job of the
notebook is to make it so you never need
a desktop each device has the goal of
moving in this direction of smaller less
confusing technology by making its more
bulky confusing neighbor obsolete
they've been so slow to update desktops
because well they're the furthest from
their vision of what a computer should
be there's a huge group of fans and
customers who think Apple has changed
that they're now obsessed with making
devices thinner at whatever cost but
this was always the goal it's just now
becoming technically possible to do so
and their products may overlap with
their competitors now but make no
mistake the second it's possible to
remove what they see as an unnecessary
distraction they will and as it becomes
easier to do so they're going to look
less and less like a technology company
at all
when Steve Jobs came back to the company
in 1997 it was a mess
they were selling a million different
products with no clear strategy so he
simplified the entire company into one
simple chart they would only make one
computer for each market but it would be
really good they've grown much bigger
since then and they've had to expand
that strategy but compared to their
competitors they're still extremely
focused to the point of leaving money on
the table their brand alone could sell
just about anything but they choose very
selectively where to focus their
attention even a good idea is not enough
to justify their making it they have to
believe it's huge this constant fear of
over complicating things is what allows
them to put so much time and so many
resources into every project they're
able to plan years and years ahead this
way investing in features that won't see
the light of day until far into the
future and if they decide something no
longer justifies their time and
attention you wake up and poof it's gone
someday that will be the iPhone it's not
that Apple doesn't listen to feedback or
even sometimes ask for it but ultimately
they consider their judgment more
important than yours
this may seem incredibly stupid but it's
actually the biggest key to their
success because without it they could
have only been successful once many
companies create a very successful
product but they milk it for as long as
possible by giving whatever customers
ask for after Microsoft created Windows
they did exactly this they're obviously
doing just fine but it meant they
weren't ready when the smartphone took
off Apple does just the opposite they're
constantly trying to compete with
themselves any other company would kill
for the success of the iPod but Apple
killed the iPod with the iPhone no one
product lasts forever so while it hurts
to kill your own success it's necessary
to stay on top in the long term this
means not listening to your customers
asking for a better iPod and instead
creating what they don't even know they
want this can be a really tough pill to
swallow especially in more tangible
forms the removal of the floppy drive
and CD drive the old charger home button
headphone jack and USB a people were
angry often for a good reason they
seemed like needless sources of
frustration and you can bet Apple knows
this but they also know they're powerful
enough to survive these transitions they
can afford to lose some customers and
receive some negative
are because the upside is huge
journalists right that these changes are
signs of a problem but the only true
danger is if they stop when they start
listening to customers they lose the
chance to make the next big thing when
the iPhone is released they'll still be
focused on improving the iPod because
frankly you and I aren't going to ask
for the next big thing we don't know
what it is but Apple has to do to them
part of their job the service they offer
is saying no we're not going to give you
what you think you want and again this
can be incredibly frustrating sometimes
they're just wrong the iPhone was late
to the big phone market because for the
longest time they thought they knew
better than we did and this mentality
can also create a bit of insensitivity
but it's a risk they have to take
because more often than not ignoring the
customer has really paid off a good
theory not only makes sense of the past
but also makes testable predictions
about the future so if these principles
really are at the heart of Apple's
thinking we can expect some specific
outcomes firstly if Apple is motivated
more by these values than pure profits
we can expect them to keep making
sacrifices that anger consumers they'll
keep investing in the Mac until a point
where they think the alternative is
better
whether that be a more powerful iPad a
hybrid device or something completely
different
before consumers are truly ready they'll
pull the plug on perfectly profitable
devices to push towards the goal of
smaller less complicated technology and
right now as we speak somewhere in
California Apple is working on something
designed to kill their current best
sellers something designed to make their
own business obsolete
this channel now has a website and it's
hosted too it's Squarespace the truth is
I never really planned on making a
website at all because I didn't think I
had the time either I'd spend a bunch of
time learning HTML CSS and JavaScript to
make it look just like I wanted or I
could make it super quickly with a
website builder but it would look
nothing like I wanted but Squarespace is
the perfect solution you don't need to
learn anything special but they give you
incredible control over the design I'm a
very picky person I knew exactly how I
wanted the website to look in my head
and I was able to make it using
Squarespace you can create a free trial
account design your website whenever you
have a few minutes and only start paying
when you're ready to go live within two
weeks you can get 10% off your first
purchase by going to squarespace.com
slash poly matter that's pol why ma tter
if you already need a website or have a
project you want to get started on this
is a great way to support the channel
thanks again to Squarespace